texas department of public safety
lieutenant chris oliveiras these numbers
are just staggering i don't even know
where to begin it must feel like uh just
it's it's
what what what should we know what
should the public know when we hear
numbers like this
600 thousand got aways almost half of
the encounters had to be released into
this country
i don't even know where to begin chris
well you're right on point charles and
and also i mean just you know thanks for
having me great to be with you so what i
can tell you it should be concerning not
only for law enforcement but for the
american people when you see the amount
of illegal immigrants that are coming
across and we're not talking about the
families or the children we're talking
about those single adults that are
coming across our border into the
interior some of those with criminal
histories criminal gang members
potential terrorists and we've seen that
also u.s border patrol has seen that as
well so this is the reality of this
current border crisis it's only going to
continue to escalate and we see that by
the numbers you know 62 000 that were
released
into the country from january
that's a staggering number compared to
the previous years and that's
unacceptable as far as releasing these
individuals into the interior when
border agents as well as our dps
personnel are trying to secure the
border by providing all the personnel
all the manpower technology in order to
apprehend these individuals and to stem
the flow of migration but again because
of the messaging and the fact that
majority of these illegal immigrants are
being related to the interior does not
help the current situation right now
where are they going once they're
released into the interior
that's a great question you know that's
a very good question uh we've known that
there's some of those flights that of
course that some of the correspondents
have been able to break some of the
stories and we've seen some of those
flights that are being flown
during the late night hours through
other states but again we don't know and
when we mentioned the guideways you know
of course those are only guideways that
are reported there's also those that
don't set off any sensors or any cameras
that we don't know who they are and we
don't know where they're at and what
their intentions are these are
individuals that are in the country
right now this is the reality of the
situation it should be very concerning
to the american people because it is a
national security threat not only to the
state of texas but to the entire country
chris when you interview these migrants
what are they telling you do they feel
uh that have they been emboldened uh by
the biden administration what was said
on the campaign trail and in the uh and
obviously the fact that the white house
is looking the other way as this happens
do they feel emboldened almost as if
they've been invited
well they do because of the messaging
the message that we saw you know back in
december 2020 um that was a whole
purpose why we're seeing this this flow
of mass migration taking place but not
only that charles we're seeing the
criminal organizations the drug
trafficking organizations exploited that
messaging they are profiting billions of
dollars off of human smuggling as well
as narcotics smuggling and because of
that we're continuing to see this influx
of illegal immigration taking place
along this on the border and it's going
to continue that was the whole reason
why governor gregory abbott launched
operation lone stars to crack down on
these organizations and also most
importantly to support our federal
partners because we know right now they
are overwhelmed and their hands are tied
they're not able to do the job that they
want to do and not being out there on
the border trying to secure it and
apprehend these individuals that are
coming across i mean that's admirable on
the part of the state but this uh this
feels like a national crisis uh is there
any hope of getting any additional
federal help
you know right now charles we are not
seeing that we don't expect that on the
state side that's why everything that we
are deploying to the southern border
with operation lone star as far as uh
technology and state funding it's all
from the state of texas from our state
leaders uh we're not getting any type of
support from the federal government also
most importantly constructing the first
ever texas border wall that's all texas
funds um again we're not seeing any type
of funds from the federal government but
of course you know that's not going to
stop us doing what we're doing right now
we're going to continue moving forward
because we have dedicated men and women
who are dedicated to this job in
securing the border and safeguarding
texans well make sure those men and
women know that we support them as well
thank you so much chris
i appreciate it thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else